moving on to other news now and another
eight cases of Marburg virus have been
confirmed by the World Health
Organization an Equatorial Guinea that
brings the total number of cases in the
country to nine since an outbreak was
first declared in February at least five
people have also died of the disease in
Tanzania the cases were confirmed in new
regions of the country indicating a
wider outbreak there are no vaccines or
antiviral treatments approved to treat
the severe viral fever and that's
fueling fears it could spread further in
the region with alarms sounding in
Cameroon and Kenya
the Marburg virus disease or MVD is a
rare hemorrhagic fever it affects both
people and non-human primates it's in
the same virus family as Ebola Marburg
has an average fatality rate of 50
percent which varies in different
strains and the worst outbreak in Angola
in 2005 the fatality rate was 88 it
killed more than 300 people well let's
get more on this now we're joined by Dr
Matthew dizoni the World Health
organization's Regional director for
Africa she's joining us from brazzaville
Congo DR Moretti thank you very much for
your time the areas that were reporting
cases and Equatorial Guinea are about
150 kilometers apart does that mean that
there are a lot more cases than what's
been confirmed
yes first thank you very much for having
invited me to join you and and share
information about this marble disease
virus yes indeed
um from the the area concerned we are
concerned it's suggestive of the fact
that there could be more the it's spread
over quite a wide wide geographic area
and as you know there have been nine
cases that have been laboratory
confirmed and 20 probable cases so the
investigation is still going on the
testing and Confirmation are still going
on of these cases
so the number of cases so far are low
but we know that it has a very high
fatality rate what does Equatorial
Guinea and Tanzania need to do to scale
up the efforts to stop the chain of
transmission here
yes
um first and foremost we need to
intensify the epidemiological
surveillance so quickly confirming
context of cases cases themselves and
the most important thing to do of course
is to stop the transmission of the virus
the the virus is transmitted in body
fluids so Blood Sweat
um saliva other body fluids so what is
very important is first of all for
healthcare workers who are some of the
first contacts and we have had a couple
of healthcare workers die in Equatorial
Guinea to make sure that they are aware
of all the precautions even as they do
their clinical care of people and the
investigations of the disease they have
the knowledge that they need and they
have the equipments that they need so
personal protection equipment gloves
masks and so forth to stop them being
infected and then very importantly at
the same time as we are understanding
further confirming the cases isolating
the k this is to make sure that we
minimize contact with other people
people in the community in the families
have to be aware of the risk of the
presence of this virus in their midst
and on of the precautions that they have
to take in order to minimize being
infected one of the
key ways of transmitting these viruses
is of course when somebody dies has
happened both in Tanzania and in an
Equatorial Guinea and then the types of
processes that have gone through to
mourn somebody to the burials but so if
burials happen at the community
it's very dangerous and that's often
also a way for the for the virus to
spread we need to have safe burials
carried out we have Partners including
non-organizations who take action to be
connected to communities first of all to
persuade them we need to convince people
you know this way of saying goodbye to
your loved one is not going to be the
normal way accept this because of the
risk and find ways to help them to do
safety safely very importantly really
it sounds like someone it sounds like
some of the challenges are those that we
faced when there was an outbreak of
Ebola Equatorial Guinea is not far from
the countries that were affected by
Ebola has Ebola equipped countries
around there to deal with such viruses
and again this virus is from the same
family as Ebola
yes I think the Ebola outbreaks both the
ones in West Africa in the Democratic
Republic of the Congo and most recently
in Uganda have equipped both the
countries affected and the neighboring
countries because we always Institute a
preparedness process investment by the
governments by the people in being
prepared for these for these outbreaks
that in a way helps us to understand
that even if if we take the the outbreak
in in Tanzania it's in an area which
borders quite closely to
Uganda to Rwanda and to Burundi but
those countries were already to some
degree prepared to deal with the
outbreak it's Thunder that does help we
have to progressively build up these
systems so that we're not starting from
scratch each time and one of them most
important aspects of this is really the
population's understanding communities
understanding and the role that they can
play because at the end of the day our
health systems don't penetrate the
communities to the degree that we can do
without their own triggers of Suspicion
and recall of this is what we were told
we needed to be careful about that needs
to be reinforced of course we need
Community Health contact with the
population so people are reminded and
enabled to minimize the transmission Dr
machidisa moiety the world health
organizations Regional director for
Africa we thank you very much for your
time on this
thank you